dylan c is going about against the team
he really likes to face this is 12 start
as era at 379.
a lot of strikeouts for innings pitch
that part of it's good left-handers
haven't done much with him
badou broke his bad adam engel charging
and adam's back
for round number one
well it's only fitting that welcome back
for the season to adam engel and the
first balls of tester little looper to
center field
[Music]
to short tim is right in front of it and
he has all sorts of time andrew the
catch inning over jose arena he's making
his 11th start
he pitched extremely well last time
against chicago here in chicago tim
anderson will lead off now the 3-2
on the ground to third
jack talked about ground ball outs
there's the first one of what we expect
will be many induced by jose arena
your means sky-high right-hand side
nomar mazzara and very short right makes
the catch and the innings over each team
has a base runner neither team scores
eric haas
leads off for the tigers in the second
inning look at that comes one to left
center field that's going to get up the
alley and all the way to the wall haas
will dig for second he's in with a
stand-up double to kickstart the second
his torrid start to his
continues well the word of the year
for shep and i is hitterish
that's what aj described eric haas
when he first saw him was hitterish
and i'm telling you he's swinging it man
with the infield in vaughan looks over
toward third goes to the bag and andrew
made a very nice play there but he did
have an available throw to third as well
three and two
cold strike three fastball paint
paint job on the outside corner bottom
two no score for the white sox and
tigers
shot up the middle backhander with a
sliding backhanded stop by goodwin
throws to first got him with a play
wow nico goodroom up one middle on a
smoked ground ball up the bat of grandal
backhanded an in-between hop as he went
to the ground and then a great pickup at
first from jonathan scope
what a play
and that's the kind of play that can
help him
that can get him going so he loud first
out here's eaton the right fielder adam
eaton down the left field line and this
is down the line in fair eaton's on his
way to second base he's thinking about
three
he's on his way to third and he stops
right there so adam eaton
at third base
with a one-out triple as the tigers went
over there to try and ferret it out of
the corner
and it took a while
well i think it shook up badou and i
don't know if he knew it was a fair ball
you see it clearly fair there
and the batter is andrew
vaughn to left in a one-nothing lead
andrew comes through on pitch number
eight and the sox lead in the second
inning that's a real good at bat
he finally got the slider he wanted only
this one didn't slide very well
stayed on the inner half
andrew hits it right on the nose
drives in his 13th run and the sox go on
top
madrigal twist this to left field big
time trouble for the tigers andrew
vaughn in a hurry to get to third and
madrigal's got himself a double so not
only is the average growing the slugging
percentage is rising two for nikki two
strikes
tim rips this ball that is smoked into
center and it will bring two
to the plate three nothing socks on a
searing line drive from ta7
he gets this ball up
it looked like it was a variation of a
change up but his change up is 90 miles
an hour and
tim drives in a pair
he's now driven in 22.
even more important than that the sox
have three up on the board
sox lead 3-0 we play the fourth now
hey it's strike three on a slider didn't
even have to chase it
this frozen
and it's literally
down the middle of the plate after the
slider two and two from cease another
breaking ball got him in between and he
racks up a second straight strikeout
two outs two strikeouts and the
strikeouts now are starting to come more
frequently dylan cease
throwing an electric slider here this
afternoon
call strike three
on a curveball
that was a clinic
thanks professor oh yeah enjoyed that
very much cease just struck out the side
looking dylan cease starting the fifth
inning and he'll face good room castro
and hill as that ball is hit well
right center field angle is back at the
wall adam jumps welcome back 15.
oh we missed you buddy
hey
game one inning five you know we've seen
a lot
of guys set up at the wall to make
catches like this
i think adam angle and kevin kiermeier
might be the two best
just an outstanding effort it takes
timing it takes agility it takes a long
glove because that one almost snuck out
of the glove
but he brings it back in what a play
nico goodram leads off the top of the
seventh one and two
heat for strike three
absolutely handcuffed good room
10 strikeouts again for cease this is a
good call by yazz because he's thinking
they've seen so many sliders and
curveballs let's just throw a fastball
and see how he reacts well he didn't
because he's looking for something else
and takes one down the middle
swinging a drive out into deep center
angle back on it makes a catch nicely
done once again liam hendricks comes
into this
nailed out his 15th save in 17 attempts
era below two
sure is
andrew vaughn
says i got it
one down
one for three a double and two
strikeouts one two
struck him out slider carved haas
13 strikeouts for sox pitching
he said when that slider is good he is
close to one hit
and that one was awfully good when
you're ahead of the hitter
one and two from hendricks
there it is
six up six down for the bullpen
dylan cease is now 7-0 in his career
against the tigers the final score
the white sox three
the tigers nothing